Google cloud next 2017 hosted a plethora
of talks detailing the future of cloud
if you didn't get a chance to catch Evan
Anderson session on DevOps with App
Engine stay tuned because here's the
recap when you've got a DevOps system in
place the biggest enemy you have is a
concept called toil toilet the work you
do today that you'll need to do again
tomorrow which is a problem because it
scales linearly with system growth and
it's work that doesn't need much
judgment or creative problem solving now
the antidote tutorial is automation as
you know there's a lot of data center
automation solutions out there already
some like a chef salt and puppet refer
to themselves as fleet management while
others like kubernetes mezzos and docker
engine are typically called container
orchestration both sets of solutions do
effectively the same things they help
you manage and deploy images and build
so that you don't go crazy but there's
another layer that removes even more of
your toil and lets you take your
application management to the next level
and that my friends is App Engine but
first here is Dickerson's hierarchy of
reliability created by the Googlers
working on the healthcare.gov project
each layer moves you from things which
are required towards things that are
just really nice to have this shot helps
us understand what we need in order to
properly provide reliability to a
service which in its core is the whole
goal behind DevOps
this is where app engine fits in when it
comes to all the tools you need to
provide reliability App Engine has you
covered let's start with monitoring
because App Engine is a platform as a
service all your top level metrics are
already logged and available things like
request latency and queue times are
automatic and can be tracked across the
application as a whole or at specific
URLs without needing to write any
application code just OpenStack driver
and all this data is exposed alongside
monitoring and inspection tools so you
can export additional metrics directly
or from logs and align them with your
instance data
next is Incident Response aka how fast
can we get back to normal when things go
wrong
is designed to automatically retain
previously deployed versions and all
audit looks when something bad happens
you can roll back to an earlier
deployment in a single action and App
Engine will handle all of the traffic
splitting and deployments to make this
happen seamlessly then there's testing
and release chances are you don't want
to test everything in production
accordingly App Engine supports multiple
concurrent deployed versions and gives
you control needed to stage releases and
balanced traffic between builds not to
mention App Engine has integrations with
a number of CI tools like Jenkins Travis
and circle CI which brings us to
capacity planning App Engine makes
capacity planning magical automatic
scaling including skill to zero for
unused versions reduces the need for
capacity planning and any reservations
finally at the very top of the pyramid
is UX this one is pretty straightforward
stack driver covers a whole suite of UX
opportunities to display your data and
monitoring information in a bunch of
different ways and you can also build
your own dashboards to get focused
insight on the numbers that matter most
to you so make sure you follow the
hierarchy of reliability and check out
the recording of Eben's full session to
see some practical examples of using App
Engine to stretch your DevOps dollar
further if you want more recaps on great
next content make sure to check out the
rest of our playlist and don't forget
the next world tour coming soon to a
city near you
[Music]
you